for more information on tutoring or how  to support moofy university and the  production of more videos please visit  moof university com thank you and enjoy  up until now we've discussed that light  which we said was energy behaves both as  a wave and as a particle which the  particles that are in light of course we  called photons what about matter  classically classical physics sort of  viewed matter as being particle like  little particles make up matter but this  was a question that was pondered by by  the physicists who eventually developed  quantum theory which kind of explains  what's going on with atoms and in  developing quantum theory they showed  that matter is wave-like which is kind  of weird but that's kind of what this  series of videos explores hope that  video was helpful thank you for watching  if you found that video helpful don't  forget to Like comment subscribe and  share with friends thank you and happy  studying